[Music]
in life is a beach news tropical
submitted by hey Ron Oh
Brazil Brazil sand king is celebrating
20 years living in a sand castle on the
beach
who's the sand king I have a third if
there was a windy night up no contest
and then they you dumb idiot shut up I
use water to like cement just all I'm
saying is ah that's scary
I know in an affair rain mm-hmm I'm not
an optimist when it comes to sand that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] fickle his name or
he goes by the name of King Marcio and
so you've been tank you have a
competition turd well I mean like
there's many kings in the world maybe
from King to King we could have a
conversation I want to live in a cave
you know like one of your moments you
know this was moments cuz I was thinking
about how in the desert people live in
caves because there's a lot cooler and
then they've actually built again so
they move out to the desert and they
living
caves and it's cool because some of
those areas have like skylights but then
that it's always cold down there yeah I
was thinking of that and then it was
really hot when I went to that place
that has a lot of stuff lag mites in
Malak tights
stalagmites and stalactites is what's
that yeah the tights are from the top my
dream okay but it was it was like a
refrigerator downstairs is so nice it
was a category like that you've been
there before
okay yeah I know you talked about bars
that uh-huh I went to one in Cancun and
they have like this whole big old place
is really nice but anyways this guy he
is 44 years old was going to be white
competition like crazy even as a [ __ ]
legit crown that shit's a plastic piece
of [ __ ] you again at the 99-cent store
you know what's so you know what soldier
would have never ever thought he was a
black person why could you think black
people can make sand castles no because
in America there's a there is a
stereotype that black people don't like
water so I don't picture mrs. sand but I
think about Jamaica yeah exactly that's
what I'm thinking like internationally
yeah that doesn't exist so - yeah why
why did that send us awesome Joe you
gotta up your game well honestly I don't
know if it's his oh but he isn't a lot
of more he's taking a picture with it
yeah he also has a book exchange thing
like he has a table next to his castle
and people could just like cuddle
exactly the book yeah Dina
yeah and so he makes money but yeah all
over explore himself Pasadena yeah they
have little cubbies like this and then
the neighborhood puts in their used
books oh you just open it and then you
just swap it out I have a lot of books
about youth in education that they could
swap that oh my god I heard euthanasia
Mike what do you have a lot of books on
euthanasia youth and education yeah
because I don't need those because it
was all I was like why are you such a I
never knew you were so much into child
development
I don't like education I pictured you
with a freaking bookshelf of like
nothing but text books and research
journals and [ __ ] I have a lot about
because I was I was a social and
education major mm-hmm you were a
sociology major yeah one of my favorite
topics by the way that's hot yes I
wanted to be a teacher so I did I do
because I like those old films where the
teachers come in and [ __ ] up the
students so that was one of my dreams I
just like sociology was flood because
literally the study of people yo soil
was [ __ ] [ __ ] and that's actually
how I found out about YouTube was
because of my specialty in psychology
was social psych type and it's a what do
you call it the interdisciplinary type
where you learn social sciences along
with the psychology and how it affects
people yeah see we smart is [ __ ] damn
you guys are smart not really because
those majors don't get you [ __ ] know
my name I have fought back but it does
help it doesn't help you buddy but it
helps you understand people yeah really
well that's true and you could be like a
lawyer so good I just like especially
education like children just because I
really wanted to go to education and I
hated how school systems run oh that's
so cool do you want to teach take off
take an Isaac like we can you can be
that I can only help them up until
algebra comes with like emotional
education and how to like solve a
problem solve but that's like what I
thought the relationship stuff yeah and
I think that's just because I love
after-school programs I thought
after-school programs were the [ __ ] and
when they were getting cut that should
piss me off a lot because I knew a lot
of kids I could have used that [ __ ] they
have nowhere to go
and it sucked that's what's gonna happen
if you guys make me rich I'm putting
that [ __ ] in the education of children
that's awesome I have a DISA for the
conspiracy that like well first off our
education is outdated as a [ __ ]
yeah and not all school systems are
created equal like you know the LAUSD
the Los Angeles School Unified School
District is different from like Texas
New York and all these other places so I
can't speak
all of the America but I know from my
experience in the inner hood Department
that our she sucked so bad dude like on
top of that you have teachers that have
a lot of heart but they also come from
like middle class lower middle class
backgrounds so there's not enough like
exposure to the outside world where you
have teachers from rich neighborhoods
and all that teaching the kids
everything that everything that they
know so it's like people just stay in
their class right but here's my
conspiracy they fill us up with a bunch
of pointless [ __ ] so we don't learn
how to do nothing so it's like imagine
you spending all these hours like text
books about booth [ __ ] and it's like
well teach me how to make money I can't
teach you to do that cuz I'm a broke
teacher too I don't know how to make
money either see that's why I don't want
to become a teacher be broke you know at
the time when I start when I when I
wanted to be a high school teacher
they started the average salary that
they would start in the district that I
wanted to work at was about 25,000
starting how the [ __ ] are you gonna live
off a you can't have broke people teach
people how to be rich it's like broke
people teaching people how to be broke
exactly so like a lot of these teachers
would have a second job $25,000 starting
right and then you get bumped in 35
after I could have made more money
working in and out I could see why who
lives in a castle now even though it is
Brazil they have any pictures of the
inside yeah there's an inside to this
thing which is pretty hell yeah I'd be
his best friend if I was a kid I'd be so
into it you know hmm
that's kind of weird he's 44 and all of
his friends are like six no you don't
know that no you have other friends cuz
sometimes he'll mention the inside of a
sand castle well at times
retain too much heat so you can't sleep
there at night so he has he's sleepover
at a friend's house or he'll just end up
sleeping over or like sleeping outside
yeah do straight up I bet you there's a
lot of women who want to be [ __ ]
inside of a castle BAM
I'm sure there's born for that and
there's a lot of girls that want to be
with yo there's actual structure yeah he
has like wood that was baby oil all over
his body
it could be someone sweat he's in Brazil
look at his library the kingdom's
library he's well-read that's dope and
then he so he'll charge people like to
take photos you know what the next photo
ok the next photo is the guy coming up
and kicking this kid off the chair get
off like this I would pay cuz I see the
value in like the time spent creating
his masterpiece I think that's amazing
yeah he thought was the art it's similar
to like Gaudi I wish I wish that that
entire sand castle is made out of cement
actually it's unbreakable so when a
[ __ ] like Logan Paul thinks he's
funny tries to come and kick it over he
just breaks his foot on well he said
that he loved the fact that he's been
living in a sand castle because sure he
doesn't mind like if it starts raining
and the whole thing collapses he's that
cool now I get to have like another
positive dude yeah and he says that he
just can't stand like he would not be
happy living in my one home like just be
trapped in like one type of home he
really likes this how he just has a
whole bunch of create creative freedom
he doesn't make his house into wherever
you want I just wish he had a moat so
it's just like alligators in it yeah
every doubt it's Brazil you have like a
big-ass Python just going around his
castle
they'll be so cool I want to go in the
castle that's why I want to go to Europe
you know you can buy castles what yeah
there's some for sale Nicolas Cage
bought some you know he's broken out
island too didn't he yeah he has not he
uses money right that's when you take
over your role that comes across well
you're afraid of castles because you
think they're haunted ah
yeah I love Catholic Oh check them out
can you imagine all the murders and rape
that it happened and all the people that
go there why would you be so special to
get hunted I don't think it's just me I
think we'd all get hunted I won't get
hung I think everyone that goes in there
gets haunted I won't get haunted and
you're with me through checkout I feel
like if I got haunted they'll just be
like what is this thing is he human
because they don't know what Japanese
people are oh that's right yeah they're
just Europeans they're just like Oh what
is this they would want you to get out
of their space
that's what but they haven't been
updated so don't even know yeah they
wouldn't even know what I am but they
might think that I'm an alien haunting
them yeah right but then you're in their
house so they're gonna try to get you is
just you sure with no eyelids
we don't believe girl you're safe do you
believe you know that's like some good
Christian talk right there don't believe
I just don't believe you're safe
[Music]
you